[Music]
all right let's go to amanda in buffalo
new york what's up amanda
hi good morning how are you doctor john
fantastic how are you
i'm all right i'm all right is it cold
in buffalo
yes we're very much ready for uh some
nice summer weather
well good i'm waving my weather wand and
i hope you get it awesome
thank you thank you so i have a question
today with dealing with a mother-in-law
um
we basically my husband and i we just
don't know how to set boundaries when it
comes to helping her understand our
comfort level with coming out for visits
as well as dealing with other things
that she often kind of throws at us in
conversation over the phone
okay tell me some
so
anytime we call her it's typically we
get the
oh you guys never call me and yet those
calls are always the ones that we sent
out
um it's never it's always a one-way
street um also she always complains that
we don't come out enough or visit
and then when we say well why don't you
come out you know we have four kids
we're kind of busy we've got a lot going
on we'd love for you to come out and
visit she has you know all her children
are grown so it's just her and her
husband
and
she just makes excuses and
when she does come out
you know she always picks a fight mainly
with me and then complains to my husband
about it
and um when we go out to her house her
one son my husband's brother half
brother
um lives there as well and it's just
there's smoking in the home there's
excessive drinking
and there's constant vulgar um talking
lots of
vulgar not even just swear words just
very vulgar in front of our young
children and we just don't feel
comfortable with it anymore we don't
know how to address it sounds like
working with kelly and james
lots of smoking and drinking and just
vulgarness
um
so
it seems
here in like on this side of the phone
it seems like a really
simple next few steps what's the hang-up
what are you hanging on to is your
husband unable to
have hard conversations is it you like
what are the challenges
yeah he definitely struggles um he
didn't really grow up with her
so i don't know if that's kind of a
hiccup but anytime i bring up like why
don't you just say something it's like
no i don't really want to say anything
and you know when we go out there it's
like it's not our house so it's not our
place to critique or judge and we don't
try to but
at the same token we have to protect our
family we're just not quite sure how to
make those boundaries known
or most more so i guess giving my
husband the aid he needs to make those
boundaries okay so
what your husband needs to make those
boundaries is a backbone
he needs to
look at his wife and you have little
ones
yeah we have four the oldest is 13 and
the youngest is three yeah he needs to
look at his four kids and say y'all are
worth
um being safe
and being protected and not having your
minds
melted and not being around dysfunction
and he needs to look at his wife and say
i love you enough to protect not protect
in like a
braveheart kind of way or like a
gladiator but protect like you don't
need to put up with that crap you don't
need to put up with someone calling you
once a month are you calling them just
you're doing your duty to be kind
and the whole conversation is where
you're lacking and where you're failing
or you're not enough
he needs to get in between you and his
mother
and so far he hasn't so
two things moving forward have you sat
down with him and said i need you to
have this conversation
or is it just this wish
okay
we have and it's just it's
mostly i don't want to you know i don't
want to basically ruffle her feathers
not with those words but
more or less i guess he just doesn't
i guess he needs the
i don't know
exactly but he needs the help so and i
don't know what that means or what that
looks like
um
it may look like you having the
conversation too
okay and
it may be hey here's what um is gonna
happen for the holidays and when you
start setting up boundaries expect
people to run as hard as they can like a
battering ram into them to see if they
hold
okay um
here's the deal we're not coming over to
your house if there's smoking and
drinking at the house and here the thing
about judgment
i judge my friends all the time i love
them too
and so i think
judgment has got a bad rap um i'll tell
my friends that's the stupidest thing of
why did you do that you're an idiot and
they do the same to me they're i've
given them permission to judge me right
and i have to judge situations all the
time for my kids and say is this a safe
one is this a is this a nursing
environment is this is a wise choice to
send you to x y or z so i'm always
judging things so i think it's fair to
look at a group of people
who continue to smoke and drink and be
super vulgar around your young children
and say i'm not putting my kids in that
environment
okay i still love you i'm glad that
you're human beings and i respect you
and great and partridge into pear tree
but i'm not gonna put my kids there
and when they come back with oh cause
you think you're better than us who me
no
i just don't want my kids around that
and here's the thing
if they want to be around your kids then
they get to choose
to quit smoking or drinking a beer
involving around your kids
it's that simple and the the switch for
your family needs to be this
mom is choosing to not be in
relationship with us
and that hurts and that stinks
right now if your husband has spent some
time estranged from his mom he's trying
to prop up a fantasy
that somehow the the disconnection was
his fault last time and he wants to make
sure it's not his fault this time
and the reality is he's got a crummy mom
a very unplugged unengaged i would say
crummy that's not cool a unplugged
disengaged struggling with her own
set of struggles mother
okay
does that sound fair
yeah absolutely absolutely she left when
he was
a young boy so and there's been a young
boy inside of him wondering what he did
wrong for a long time and i got her back
and he's not about to
be the person who puts the gap in that
relationship even if it hurts his kids
and even if it causes separation with
his wife
that makes sense it is hard
and it's the next right move
or just quit calling
that's the other i mean just stop
calling
okay well
we've done that where we've gone some
time without talking and then she calls
him what did i do wrong what did i make
you mad and it's just that you know that
shaming and that guilt like what
and then he could say no
like you know i mean like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna give that type of
uh my friend dave what's he say that
sometimes parents can be a travel agent
for guilt trips right i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna carry that brick for you the
oh and now i suck as your kid or now i'm
a bat like no i'm gonna carry that for
you you can hand it to me i'm not gonna
hold it that's yours to carry if you
wanna carry that around
um
if she's somebody who can hear then he's
like yeah man phones work both ways
highways do too
and by the way when you're in our house
there is no smoking inside there's no
smoking outside if you don't want it um
you guys may have to put the alcohol
away
even if you have wine and good bourbon
up in the cabinet when your
mother-in-law and her husband are in
town you put the alcohol away because
you're gonna live by example
and if somebody says something in front
of your kid and i've done this with
family members when they're telling a
joke or saying something i've stopped
him and said no stop
not in this house and especially not in
front of my children
and it's been uncomfortable
and it stopped
and then they got a choice to make do i
want to be in relationship with a guy
who doesn't want me saying those type of
jokes around his kids
does that make sense and i know i'm
making it sound very light and it's
taking me a decade to get where i'm at
now so it's not easy
um
but it's really really important and
here's some small potatoes um my parents
have a small house where they live they
live in kind of a patio home
and so when we go we get a hotel
and it's better for all of us
we all get sleep they all get sleep and
sometimes my kids will spend the night
in their guest room but it's just better
for everybody and then they have their
evenings and then we've got so it works
for our family and they were it wasn't
weird when we said hey this is how we're
going to do this and they were great
about it and so sometimes it takes that
mutual um maturity on both sides but hey
here's gonna be the best thing for our
family we're not gonna get there until
midnight so we're gonna get a hotel and
we're gonna stay here and it's got a
pool here so we can burn off some energy
and
so it just works for our family you know
what i'm saying so we've just set up
some boundaries along the way um and i'm
just grateful that my parents and my
in-laws are are great at having those
conversations but
um at the end of the day
your husband has to say my kids and my
wife are worth more than the fantasy of
me trying to prop up
a mother who abandoned me once and i'm
worried is gonna abandon me again
and that's hard
no question about heart
i'd love to see you all get together and
plan hey what do we want the holidays to
look like what do we want our lives to
look like and then we're going to
backfill that with the relationships
that we have and those that we're going
to have to marginalize and if somebody's
not respecting your
vulgarity wishes your drugs and alcohol
and whatever whatever you whatever world
you all have constructed for yourselves
then it's up to you to put up boundaries
and say that relationship's not going to
be a part of our life anymore
and that's hard
and i'll say it again and that's really
hard
and there's freedom on the other side of
that conversation though